[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about way yeah we want
brief live enough here's having you all
fall slipping him off oh thank you God
technically I was doing it to myself
because I was doing it to the reflectors
you came back to me no skills watch and
forget employment both again I do I do
but it's blowing out not in doesn't
matter in your mountain and maybe like
scratches is back within he hasn't the
back recently yeah sure he does that
somebody out there just stumbled on this
channel they clicked on this video they
saw Joe was blowing the flute through
his nose and then they we reached over
and click Subscribe come on baby you
know that's what it's all about people
stayed for this that's right come to the
show Mauri thanks what are we gonna talk
about today whatever we want more anyone
ever had you ever want to talk about
something but you don't get to but now
you get to you guys anything you ever
wanted to get off your chest you want to
tell us everything about Smosh I feel
like there's not even any dirt it's like
it came from but it just make something
up give us something yeah the the the
studio has Disneyland Park inside of it
Smosh was a front the whole time and
they were running drugs pretty cool was
actually like a straight-up drug lord
yeah that's right his real name is a
Tony and that that's his full name Wow
Ian chose Anthony is a full name yeah
III feel like I wish there was more dirt
but I think it came from a bad place and
then now it's it's going into a better
place and OH
success stories yeah are you wearing a
destiny jacket I sure AM
that's destiny it's a game ideal game I
don't know anything about that
is it fun is it good I was very obsessed
with the first destiny game I'm in one
for no one know I play I played a
healthy amount of 2 as well but I think
I got sidetracked with other games I
came out what do you play I would like
right now apex
I still love apex scares me oh so much
pressure what is it about uh I don't
know what it's about
honestly it's like if there's only 3
people on the team so I feel like
there's a lot of pressure like each
person needs to like hold their own
pretty oh yeah I got a question for you
wait is this like an interview show a
rock we're drilling it really bored of
each other and your new date today but I
got a question for you okay since you're
a gamer right you call yourself a gamer
yes since you're a gamer um and you know
how video games working you love video
games yeah if you were to have a kid
would you have the kid follow of those
age requirements for games or would you
go hey you know what you're not like a
lot of people it's like the kid to be
like 5 and he just straight murdering
people yeah the game whatever right like
would you let the kid kid like would you
have any censorship with high games they
give the kid could play
I mean honestly I think this is a way
like my husband and I are like we're not
gonna have kids because I think there's
so many questions of like how do you
raise a kid like in this society now and
it's like there's there's so there's so
much now yeah like there's you know like
you you have a phone and you can access
literally anything and that's pretty
crazy yeah I have nephews who are 9 and
7 yeah and I feel like they didn't play
any video games until they were like I
want to say like around 6 and 8 yeah so
they got bullied yeah no I I don't you
know not really I don't think like you
don't play the games that we play Oh
gamers are now bullying non-gamers like
what do you don't play games your video
only because kids that's how they play
now like they don't go out to play they
just go on they play for
like I'll see on fortnight oh my god
that's so true I think does that you
comes home from school and it's like
alright mom let me just play a piano
really quick am i practicing can't go in
fortnight now ya hear him talking to his
friends then playing basketball we'd be
yeah it's the same [ __ ] yeah am I crazy
but before I think for nine kind of
blows mine
I don't even know what that is I'm a
fortnight you it's okay if you do this
is another thing where it's like I feel
a lot of pressure when I play for at
night but they expect you to be good
yeah I just feel like I have a lot of
like I'm like I want to do really well
for my team so if I'm not really good at
it I'm like you know what this is just
not the game for me and there's plenty
of other games
that that I feel like I you know oh
that's so funny I used to play you
remember you know counter-strike mm-hmm
I used to play that ball yeah I would I
just suck so hard at that game I would
[ __ ] piss my team the [ __ ] off dude I
used to I used to throw a flashbang as
soon as we went in and then the whole
team would sink would get flashbang
though it's good I was like sorry guys
wrong button [ __ ] I was applying be a
hero and you think you're doing the
right thing no not me I wanted to [ __ ]
with somebody in the troll yeah dude we
went to Florida last year and we went to
like this arcade and Ready's yeah it's
sick what David Buzz is trying to be
yeah like this racing game and we suck
right we all suck we're all crashing
into stuff and we're all trying to get
the hang of the steering wheel and cuz
it's like virtual reality is it's
[ __ ] suit um so then we're playing
and we're all trying to beat each other
and then this [ __ ] out of nowhere
starts crashing into all of our cars for
no reason because it's funny the
Friendly Fires I'm thinking you're the
friendly fire guy on purpose I'm the
friendly fire guy not on purpose I see
you're just trying to help your team win
I'm really trying like I didn't know
that was the grenade I think it's cuz I
suck at games so bad that I'm angry at
games oh but I also think that a lot of
people especially back when I played
games a lot like counter-strike people
think it's so [ __ ] serious that I
just can't
can't yeah that ran on that [ __ ] I mean
that was like the beginning of that kind
of stuff yeah yeah so okay so to go back
on the question of like how do you
measure kids and what they play I don't
know I mean you know you wouldn't you
wouldn't know if you if you would have
every kid follow it or not I think
following is definitely like that would
be the the good parameters to try to go
for cuz I feel like that's the minority
I feel like most people don't really
have it it's like our movies right like
we all watched it when we were like 13 I
feel like most people don't follow like
like the random 12 year old that's
surfing Netflix is part of watching hell
and rated-r [ __ ] I don't know I mean
like when we were kids like I'm sure
we've we watched a ton of like our Sol
reservoir dogs that like 5th grade or
something oh yeah I was seeing titties
5th grade 6th grade Freddy Krueger yeah
I got boners off the bat the way we grew
weird yeah not Freddy Cooper but the
scenes today like titty scenes because
of the way we grew up though Casey
always wants to let Isaac watch like
rated our movies or like way crazier
movies and I'm like no like that was the
way we grew up that's not the new way
like the new standard whatever like I
don't care if we saw we did our movies
and we were 10 like I'm not gonna let
Isaac do that what grade is he now
he then 5th grade oh he's seen it now
yeah we've been like whatever he's been
exposed to it his dad I can't control
that and I know he's been exposed to
some [ __ ] over there like I know for
[ __ ] cuz he fell he goes back in like
he's humming certain things from certain
movies or I'm like wait how'd you it's a
masterpiece that's a classic mom is a
classic no and then so like I know he's
being exposed to things I can't control
in his dad's and I'm like well that's
just out of my hand I can't do nothing
about that but when he's in my house
he's not watching that [ __ ] he's not
being exposed to that [ __ ] what's your
thought process behind it well because
for me it's like there's age
restrictions for a reason right like
when a child is developing his mind like
his mental health like it's not if it's
not appropriate like if more like
smarter more educated people have
research this should have determined
that a child at the age of 10 can't
watch a pg-13 movie or whatever then
that's
I'm just gonna follow that cuz I'm like
there's professionals that I already
figure this [ __ ] out like I'm not gonna
try to go against that don't on the flip
side so like let's say I agree with you
and I think whatever you want to do it
can I think that's ultimately your
choice but just playing devil's advocate
like on the flip side if professionals
figured out that algebra is for eighth
graders but he figured it out when he's
in fifth grade are you gonna stop him
there - no of course not because and
that's like that's helping there's no
element of mental risks yeah so no
emotional risk so watching our movie
what is the benefit but bargah risk
development like like um they usually
deal with themes that are maybe more
like there's emotional development right
right see what words say no Bart saying
that like um if you're if like when
you're in this age you're capable of
thinking like way above you're like you
know we all know people who are like
it's like I can't wait this person is
only this age because they're so cool
for their age and I um well because of
that reason I'm not like super rigid on
that rule I'm not like nope it's a pg-13
movie you're only 11 years old you're
not gonna watch it no I'm not like that
either because I try to watch the movie
first before I before I allow him to
watch it or gloss pretty tight or if
we're in the theater and like it's a
pg-13 movie and there's like a lot of
violence when he was younger now I feel
like he's matured too because you also
have to know your kid yeah yeah I know
my kid I know we can handle what he you
know like whatever he could be exposed
to so if I know he can handle whatever
he's watching then that's fine but when
he was younger he would go watch older
movies like I'll cover his eyes are all
like I'll be like no this is a little
too extreme or whatever so I'll try it -
doing Garfield or something
No do you remember being that agent I'm
not even really debating with you it's
just so interesting because I remember
being ten in a movie theater my dad
reaching over covering my eyes during
the city scene and I was like I've seen
Diddy's this guy can [ __ ] close my
eyes if you want yeah really don't know
I know cuz I've been in those shoes too
like I've been I remember my parents
would cover my eyes when there would be
people kissing like just kissing and I'd
be like that would make me want to see
it even more that's really there
meaning that I mean in our situation my
parents will be live dangerous minds
with my mom and [ __ ]
and I was like super young and I came
out of there and moms like the the the
high school scene that's the high school
near us and that's the only thing that
she commented on about Dangerous Minds
it was a high school that was that
that's the high school that I went
happens in the movie that's so I mean
it's all gangster stuff gangsters drugs
yeah sex thing cuz like my mom let me
watch American Pie when I was like 13
that's wild I know but she the bad scene
it's just I've been a pirate know what
Shannon Elizabeth it's like naked in
them yeah she's a foreign exchange
student she let me watch it but she
cause she already saw him before me so
then she was like cuz I kept hearing
about it at school and I kept asking her
and I'm like can you see it whatever I
should like okay fine I'll let you see
it but I have to fast-forward all the
crazy parts so then like right before
something crazy what happens she pause
it
she'd be like okay go over there so I
wouldn't see this so then you're like
what's this movie about never saw the PI
[ __ ] see that's the [ __ ] the whole
[ __ ] fast-forward that part about when a
dog's [ __ ] them is that part too I
don't remember what happened forgotten
it a lot yeah like the dog gets into
that and then the door opens and the
whole family comes out for me though
because I felt like cool I got to see
like I I kind of understand enough of
you got the CliffsNotes yeah it's a
feeling like I don't I'm not missing out
anymore I always wonder like that stuff
like with the video games and everything
because there's like there's video games
and there's like there's always backlash
or pros and cons or negative or positive
effects for everything and I kind of
like feel the same way about movies or
even about like like the math example I
brought it with algebra and there's even
that was like sports right like there's
certain sports you need your bodies to
be a certain way like the Tyco riding up
learning how to ride a bicycle right on
spy a bad idea does not balance she's
gonna have scrapes and bruises all over
his face so there's a certain age we
want them to ride a bike but what if at
- all of a sudden he's like way ahead of
the curve then do I want to hold him
back yes there's a lot of injuries and
there's a lot of negative things and
physical trauma that he can have and I'm
always just like wondering like
as a gamer is that to me is usually the
out of everything that's put on the
table that's age restricted gaming is
usually the number one thing is just
people oh yeah because of this violence
there that school beating kids up or
whatever you know just like if we have a
gamer yeah I mean like to your point
like the Shaun White's of the of the
world right like he was you as
snowboarding when it was like really
dangerous and it was like tiny and he
was little and he was still doing it
yeah and you know most eSports players
are super young they're like 16 17 years
old because their twitch muscles were so
close 13 yeah so that for sure have they
for sure have been playing games way
older than what suited for them right
mm-hmm yeah it's an interesting question
and you know I think we're living in a
world where it's so easy to try to like
keep kids away from so many things now
when we actually grew up on a time where
it was just like we were exposed to a
lot of things because I think our
parents were exposed at the same time
and they were looking at new technology
and stuff too and so it's like I'm gonna
protect the world because I know my
kid's gonna have psychopathic tendencies
huh so I'm like not even for the kid to
for their mind it's like if that
[ __ ] playing this game he might
not know reality from fake and he might
kill people he might be like me yeah so
when I was a kid my parents restricted
me from all sex things and now you're so
horny right that's what I'm saying
I went the other way I and they were
like don't use that words I went the
other way there you know everything
about me is because my parents tried to
repress all that same it's all the
deltas you [ __ ] me up dude I used to
think that sex was bad yeah because the
do you equate it with bad so like one
time my mom caught me in a bookstore I
was like trying to read a row like a
[ __ ] sex scene in a romance novel cuz
I wanted to understand sex and [ __ ] yeah
and I got was punished for that and like
so [ __ ] like that [ __ ] with a kid and
it makes them remember that sex and
things that we all like who doesn't want
to have more sex than a life like with
their partner or whatever like that's a
good thing isn't it well no because some
people are psychologically [ __ ] about
sex yeah and so them they attributed
Shane for mom and dad
yeah and so it affects them later on in
life all these guidelines actually not
scientific a lot of its religious based
MPAA [ __ ] that they shove down our
[ __ ] throats because they're afraid
to actually talk to their kids about
sets or violence or drugs or whatever
that's what that's what it is yeah I
mean the [ __ ] off I'm all religious base
it's a religious [ __ ] class system
and then and then we're all supposed to
raise our kids according to the way that
the church wants wants us to raise our
kids and I say [ __ ] that
unless it's scientifically proven right
in many cases it's like every generation
has it's like oh let's blame the movies
let's thank you lets playing cartoons
yeah it's clean there's no evidence
there's no evidence yes Gary sometimes
even the scientists because they're
religious they're trying to push their
religious agenda through science and
they kind of art things a certain way to
anything the MPAA
is not set up from studies and [ __ ] that
[ __ ] is step set up from well there is
no it sticks up their asses like being
religious dictators in there are little
houses there is some well correlation
with like for example Ted Bundy and
serial killers that enjoy horror movies
that slay women mm-hmm or like you know
there's child killers in Japan like
child like what do you call it like
they're chill
they're not children killers they're
kids that kill kids right and they
though they'll just watch horror movies
like non-stop all day long and then they
get obsessed and then they go out and
they look for other kids to kill and
chop them up and [ __ ] like they're what
Ted Bundy it was also tied with like
sexual frustration right and we precious
I think molested and oh yeah like all
these other weird things and then but
yeah yeah it was
he started associating sexual behavior
with horror and slashing and things like
that but the tail didn't wag the dog
right well I mean like you're gonna have
you're one in a million
mm-hmm you know in in any case in any
case but it's it is it is kind of
supplying a pleasure for those type of
people and then making it okay we're
trying to set up laws for the many fruit
treating everyone like a psychopath is
not right though
and that's where parenting comes into
play right because if you're younger and
I mean you should be supervising the
youth and and seeing if this participant
ly watching war movies and there's like
weird behavior you kind of want to
question that and step in and talk about
most cases this happens because parents
are not there or they're drugged or
they're gone or they're on drugs dude
they're beating up their own kids or
their [ __ ] their own kids neela in
Europe you turn on the TV you see nudity
Tosa Elvis is not so crazy so passionate
about in Europe you turn on the TV you
see nudity you see sex things see that's
not bad and there's not more murder not
more no these commercials daytime
commercials there's new diesel we're the
ones who do this religious orthodoxy
[ __ ] and in that holding back
actually makes us crazier makes us
[ __ ] machines I learned just a few
days ago that like Japan used to be
super hyper sexual and like like all the
artwork and stuff used to have like
nudity all over the place and then it
wasn't until like Westerners came in or
we're [ __ ] Neanderthals for doing
that and then now we're even more
hornier damn yeah it's sexual oppression
there so don't be oppressed by sex yeah
so yeah if you want to raise your kid
and you're like I'm gonna wait till
they're 13 for pg-13 it's not cuz the
[ __ ] it's not as a science or
anything you want bored about that if
it's your personal preference that's
great yeah but like you don't the worry
about like oh somebody smarter than me
figured it out already and I'll just go
by their guidelines you know T DS T DS
were never wrong in Japan and if you
became wrong because titties are never
these are never wrong like it's it's the
Western perspective that T's are wrong
right you got to cover up your [ __ ]
barbarian but um there's Easter divert
women there were like they're like this
is uncomfortable to wear anything on
holding Europe right now like it's like
yeah just the t's were out right it's an
elbow
basically it reads body good nipple
right the titty get them out get them
out right I really get them out just let
the titties hang out deliberate women
though so you're saying don't worry
about the guidelines
yeah well I I don't get what the grain
of salt that's what I do
so that is what I do so if it's like a
crazy-ass rated-r movie like a Tarantino
movie and [ __ ] I'm like okay my 10 year
old kid cannot like I said that's a
personal preference and usually that's
your decision and I fully support that
but I wouldn't look to person and ivory
tower MPAA or whatever and say like well
hey they're covering it for me like [ __ ]
that my second great by 2nd grade I knew
this was created at a film set or this
was drawn as a cartoon like by that time
if you don't understand you're [ __ ]
[ __ ] that kids a [ __ ]
you got to wait a little bit longer
until they understand that this is all
fake [ __ ] like once you recognize that
it's fake [ __ ] yes it's still scary but
then I think it changes your perception
about this is entertainment and this is
not affecting me like it's reality
yeah like when I was surprised to watch
movies with my mom she covered me from
all the sexual stuff to I'm not the
fighting not the fighting because I
think this is part of martial arts and
it was cool but I think one thing that I
always thought was pretty cool was like
and she also just realized lecturing me
any time watching a movie the theme that
she always stressed is like the
transformation of character so I think
because of that and also knowing like in
second grade that movies like are just
shot on the film say like Indiana Jones
is shot somewhere else he's not really
actual Explorer or whatever he's just an
actor so when I started watching movies
with that lens no matter how gory or
whatever it is I just understood all
it's just a way to tell the story and in
the transformation of character and
that's kind of the things that I focused
on so I feel like the parents the kids
that are left at home and just were able
to watch all the crazy ass movies
without any guidance those are the ones
they're probably gonna have trouble but
if you have someone that's either
covering the eyes or doing some sort of
teaching teaching so it's guiding their
mindset if they're if they are absorbing
content that's above their normal age
but if they can be guided and
categorized in this early what we try to
do to like as well if we go to the
theater
see the movie before or whatever and
then we end up seeing some [ __ ] he'll
ask this question obviously like I guess
so we'll guide him through whatever it
was that he was exposed to and that's
dope that's parenting that's it yes
thanks because I know of all that [ __ ]
and I went through it myself cuz it like
hiding the kisses from me whatever just
made me want to look so horny now
exactly I'm so [ __ ] horny all the
time nah nothing like I always try to
have that conversation available for him
like forever ever since he was a little
little kid like I always try to make it
very clear like sex is normal
yeah your body's normal talk to me about
whatever
like in fourth grade my friend's dad let
us borrow his playboy cuz we like the
articles if anything I think our
generation has become really really good
with communicating whether it's like
with each other it's like way better
than our parents my parents are at bat
see way faster so they're more mature so
it's like it's being able to talk to
your kids frankly right and just just
being able to lay it out because they
are sponges and they're so capable of
learning so much and if you're there to
guide them to be like this was this and
you know this is what happened or
whatever it is I think they can learn so
much dude I never got the sex talk I
still don't even know what what is it I
didn't get one my mom just told me not
to buy hookers what she really told me
you hate ninth grade but I've been
saving up
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
[Music]